eu já fiz a viagem de são paulo até o
aeroporto de guarulhos pelo menos nas
500 vezes mas nenhuma delas do tanto
tempo quanto a última viagem na última
semana eu estava indo pro chile em uma
viagem de negócios
entrei num táxi me acomodei em e muito
rapidamente o taxista começou a puxar
conversa comigo que me conhece um pouco
sabe que eu sou de poucas palavras com
estranhos e que eu aproveito normalmente
as viagens de táxi olhar a paisagem que
aqui em são paulo não é assim tão bonita
para estudar até para trabalhar mas
nesse dia foi um pouquinho diferente no
mundo em que a gente está vivendo hoje
no momento político difícil no país e
certamente a conversa não poderia ser
outra e o taxista começou a falar sobre
uma série de coisas quando ele disse pra
mim que coincidência ontem eu peguei
três passageiras nesse mesmo lugar que
eu peguei a senhora hoje levando também
para guarulhos
mas a viagem não foi assim tão agradável
mesmo ele elas começaram a falar sobre
esse ou aquele candidato defendendo esse
e aquele motivo e eu fui ficando tão
estressado com aquele assunto que a
minha vontade é jogar aquelas pessoas
pela janela
rapidamente me lembrei da minha época de
comissária de bordo não coloquei a mão
no cinto de segurança olhei pra direita
e pensei essa é a saída que eu tenho que
pegar
obviamente faltava muito tempo para
chegar no aeroporto de guarulhos
e eu me preocupei com o tom daquela
conversa eo quanto tempo aquela viagem
iria durar a noite é verdade eu fiquei
preocupado
um pouco mais pra frente e o papo foi
avançando e eu só concordava com um sim
ou não em rinha e coisas assim
até que ele disse assim pra mim você
sabe que eu tenho pelo passageiros nessa
época eles têm falado sobre tantas
coisas mais uma realmente me irritou
ela falava comigo sobre diversidade e me
disse que existe uma tal de uma nova lei
de cotas
para lgbt e o ri se
sério me interessei de fato quando a
gente fala de um sistema de lei de cotas
muitas pessoas detestam outras adoram um
mas não é um tema fácil de conversar mas
em especial eu me interessei por aquele
assunto e não tinha fundamento a
conversa que ele falava
até que ele disse pra mim e já estava
muito perto do porto graças a deus e ele
disse assim moça sabe eu tenho uma
preocupação
vejam que foi um monólogo né não farei
nada de guarulhos
ele disse eu tenho uma preocupação eu
tenho dois filhos homens ea minha
preocupação e eu saio todos os dias da
minha casa com um propósito de criar os
meus filhos para que eles sejam
exatamente como eu cozinho amigo no
modelo de família que eu acredito que o
homem e mulher com vivendo junto em
harmonia e eu disse assim obrigada pela
viagem até logo
quando eu cheguei obviamente ele já
tinha descido do carro e fui pro chile
foi naquela viagem de avião cheguei no
hotel e fiquei pensando que momento
estamos vivendo hoje que significa falar
dessa pessoa de verdade por mais que às
vezes pareça engraçado pra mim não foi
muito aquela viagem no escuro com o
desconhecido falando de coisas de uma
forma tão incisiva e às vezes até
agressiva sobre a falta de respeito ao
ser humano realmente me atingiu muito e
fiquei alguns dias a ballack abalada com
aquilo eu sou adriana ferreira e meu
propósito de vida que eu descobri faz
muito tempo é trabalhar com um e para as
pessoas
e hoje eu vim falar com você de um tema
que é muito importante que é a
diversidade
embora muita gente diga que diversidade
e nova eu tenho um pensamento um
pouquinho diferente disso e vou falar
sobre isso com vocês hoje diversidade
por si só não inova existem outros
fatores que juntos podem nos levar a
inovação que a gente tem externa
não é exatamente uma inovação
tecnológica mas eventualmente uma
inovação de novas idéias novas formas de
pensar em novas maneiras de ser novos
modelos de família e aí eu reflito muito
sobre inclusive nas platéias nem onde eu
falo e queria começar com exercícios com
vocês até uma pergunta que eu esqueça de
fazer no começo eu tenho uma pessoa com
deficiência visual aqui cego porque eu
ia escrever um pouco o ambiente se caso
houvesse eu queria que vocês olharem
para o lado um pouco e levantasse a mão
a pessoa que estiver sentado ao lado de
um negro ou uma negra
só muda assim pode levantar alguma
pessoa com deficiência física cadeirante
verdade não podia deixar de ser lutava o
meu estagiário a quem me prestigiando
hoje em um pouco estranho que nós
sejamos mais de 7 bilhões de pessoas no
mundo e há já três ou quatro metros e
sala num país onde quase 54% da
população se considere afrodescendente
eu acho estranho e acho também que nesse
mundo de sete bilhões de pessoas vai ser
muito difícil que a gente encontra
alguém que tem se igual cima da gente
isso me instiga porque eu trabalho numa
corporação que eu gosto muito que
respeito e acredito nos seus valores mas
a maioria das corporações dos gerentes e
líderes e executivos das empresas
insistem em contratar e procurar
currículos de pessoas que são quase
iguais linhas a eles e aí eu penso que a
vida é como uma linha de partida é a
nossa vida nossa carreira nossa vida
pessoal
essa imagem pra mim diz muito pra mim
sobre isso porque algumas pessoas ou
todos nós partimos de algum momento
quando iniciamos
a nossa carreira quando vamos para a
escola quando mudamos a nossa carreira
para uma nova parte de algum lugar
qual é a diferença do mundo que a gente
vive hoje em um país como o nosso com
outros países da américa latina é que
nem todas as pessoas vão partir da mesma
reta de partida mas dri por que isso
acontece
eu não sei por que isso acontece mas eu
posso te garantir que as pessoas que não
estão partindo daí são porque tem uma
cor diferente da maioria de vocês uma
orientação sexual diferente da maioria
de vocês uma condição física diferente
da maioria de vocês e portanto às vezes
pelo simples fato de nascer como é
não vai partir daqui portanto não vai
chegar no mesmo lugar que muitos de
vocês chegaram ou chegaram
estou convicta disso e aprendi muito
nessa minha jornada e no mundo
corporativo onde estou há 10 anos
exatamente na verdade faço amanhã 10
anos que eu trabalho na empresa que eu
estou hoje
e eu me lembro muito bem de uma campanha
pra mim é emblemático e marca assim foi
um momento em que eu realmente acordei
para a questão da diversidade e inclusão
que foi o mês de maio onde a gente
estava comemorando o mês das mães e eu
pedi a uma empresa um time de
comunicações que enviassem imagem de uma
mulher que eu precisava colocar naquela
comunicação uma imagem escreveu um texto
e aquele meio eu olhei pra essa foto e
eu pensei bota real e esta mulher não me
representa tem mais aqui
algumas mães talvez elas até represente
vocês e não há nenhum problema de ser
uma mulher linda e loira no campo de
margaridas certo não há nenhum problema
nesse o problema é que essa mulher não
representa um décimo das mulheres da
empresa onde eu trabalhava ea pessoa que
me mandou isso era de comunicações e eu
pensei
deus onde nós vamos parar e eu fiquei
pensando depois até me preparando pra
vir aqui como é que eu poderia confluir
momento da minha vida que eu mais me
aproximei dessa imagem
foi nesse momento eu tinha hoje os 6
anos 7 anos
meu irmão cali e prestigiando também
deve lembrar desse nosso quintal né
isso não é um milharal é o fundo da
nossa casa onde nós vivemos na periferia
de são paulo morando num como de cozinha
com os meus pais
eu e meu irmão que está aqui bom eu não
parecia nem um pouco qualquer mulher é
verdade além de ser uma criança e tudo
mais mas quando eu vi essa foto e peguei
essa foto para vir falar com vocês eu
pensei eu tinha sonhos nessa época eu
não sabia o que o mundo seria pra mim
com as escolhas que eu teria sendo filho
de nordestinos e vendo na periferia
eu não sabia mas eu tinha sonhos um
deles era ser astronauta
o outro era ser professora e vocês não
vão acreditar mas eu pensei em ser a lei
outorga e eu até sabia falar essa
palavra quando tinha 6 ou 7 anos de
idade eu amava o mundo dos dinossauros
tinham os filmes em preto e branco que a
minha época né e que eu assistia os
dinossauros eu achava aquilo muito
incrível e alguns desses sonhos se
tornaram realidade
eu já fui instrutora hoje dou palestras
também faz do curso da empresa onde o
trabalho e cheguei muito perto do céu
na verdade eu fui comissária de bordo
não cheguei na lua embora tenha nascido
no ano em que o homem chegou à lua eu
nunca consegui conquistar esse sonho e
acho que nessa vida não vou mas desculpa
eu fui comissária de bordo durante muito
tempo antes da profissão que eu tenho
hoje e ser comissária me levou a vários
lugares do mundo eu conheci o lago
focará no nepal e o fui para brotas
caminhar nas cavernas
eu fui para o valle nevado e para mais
talvez 27 países durante a minha vida
como comissária isso me trouxe muita
experiência de vida com as pessoas e
ouvir e conversar com pessoas de muitas
religiões de muitas nacionalidades de
muitas crenças e fui aprendendo ao longo
da minha vida a respeitá las e entendê
las mas fazer estipulo daquele quintal
onde morava em itaquera para o lugar
onde eu estou hoje todos os lugares que
eu passei então foi difícil mas uma
coisa que se conecta muito com as
palestras anteriores e e fico muito
feliz por isso é que os meus pais sempre
me incentivaram a estudar e nunca
abriram mão - mesmo nos momentos muito
difíceis de que eu e meu irmão fossemos
para a escola e isso pra mim é muito
importante também significa muito para
mim
no entanto esse pulo e acreditar que é
possível estar em algum lugar e eu
sempre gostei muito de viajar e acredita
que um dia podia ser astronauta como eu
disse se tornou verdade sempre com o
apoio da minha família do meu irmão e
dos meus amigos mas foi durante aquela
corrida de táxi para o aeroporto durante
a minha trajetória como comissária e
agora nem precisam de um trabalho que eu
realmente descobrir que diversidade 9
porque isso de nada basta a gente tem
uma empresa com teoricamente bastante
diversa
se as pessoas não se sentem incluídas
isso pode ser realmente um problema o
que significa essa inclusão com a
inclusão que a gente busca a inclusão
que eu prego e que eu ea empresa onde o
trabalho que nós acreditamos é aquela
que olha o indivíduo pelo seu potencial
estávamos esses dias conversando sobre
processos seletivos em que o recrutador
cento à sua frente pergunta primeiro a
sua idade se você é casado que faz o fim
de semana qual é seu hobby que isso tem
a ver com a vaga que você vai se aplicar
não muito então se os esquilos e à sua
vivência são descartadas e eu passei por
essa dificuldade porque a companhia
aérea em que eu trabalhava faliu e aos
38 anos e olhei pro lado não
tinha nada onde pudesse me apegar a não
ser o amor da minha família
imaginem que eu tinha um trabalho que
era um ambiente mais ou menos assim com
essa quantidade de pessoas um longo
corredor onde eu servia tic no bife
rocco water
essa era minha vida e esse é o inglês
que eu falava naquela época e me
reorganizando procurando uma nova
maneira de ser e de estar no mundo eu me
candidatar a uma vaga de estágio e eu
fui devo ter sido até hoje está gera
mais velha da empresa onde o trabalho e
que requereu muita coragem para estar lá
para dar muitos passos para trás e
chegar onde estou hoje e ouvir histórias
nessa trajetória histórias ricas de
pessoas que foram à correntaria dadas ao
descobrirem e e se identificarem com uma
deficiência se perceberem pessoas com
deficiência se perceberem negros porque
acreditem negros e negras não se percebe
negro simplesmente pelo fato de terem
nascido assim a discriminação eo
preconceito é que mostra para ele qual é
o caminho que esse mundo tá levando e
novas e desculpe e incluir realmente
pode inovar e trazer pessoas para perto
respeitá las ou vilas juntar os times
respeitá los entender que a orientação
sexual não necessariamente igual à sua
mas também não significa que pode ser
uma coisa ruim e pensando que é possível
inovar e que talvez um ambiente das
empresas não estejam não só preparados
mas talvez seja tarde demais para fazer
essa inovação na empresa eu resolvi
fazer uma coisa diferente na empresa
onde trabalho e juntei pessoas que
acreditam nisso pessoas que estão aqui
hoje me prestigiando pessoas que
resolveram sair do lugar comum e
começamos a fazer um trabalho que se
chama respeito em foco é uma iniciativa
onde nós vamos até escolas públicas e
particulares falar com crianças a partir
de 10 anos de idade sobre o que é
respeito
o que é o mundo que a gente vive e como
você
cada um de nós pode transformar o mundo
num mundo melhor
essas são as crianças fazendo as
atividades que nós propomos para elas
atividades que falam sobre direitos lgbt
equidade de raça pessoa com deficiência
e empoderamento feminino
nós utilizamos design fim como uma uma
ferramenta poderosa para engajar essas
crianças e movê las propósito que a
gente quer que é de ter essa discussão
na base quando o preconceito ainda não
está enraizado e através desse trabalho
a gente consegue retornos absolutos já
ouvi histórias lindas as crianças
constroem não só debatem o problema que
elas têm em sala de aula como constroem
uma solução pra aquilo que acha que pode
ser um mundo ideal e eu vou tentar que
em poucos minutos contra uma das
histórias pra vocês que me toca
pessoalmente tenho visto muita coisa de
violência contra a mulher isso realmente
tem se tornado um assunto muito sério no
nosso país e nós propomos uma situação
em que uma mulher é casada com um cara
do tipo machista que simplesmente só
fica assistindo televisão no sofá e pede
para pegar cerveja na geladeira um
estereótipo é verdade isso não acontece
a gente assim só um exemplo mesmo tá
elas discutem o tema e essas crianças
quando propuseram uma vida diferente
para essa mulher a primeira coisa que
eles fizeram foi obviamente separar o
casal
sugeriram o divórcio e ali e eles
desenham isso nesses meses ans
nesse clipe chaves e eles desenharam
essa mulher num novo relacionamento
e ele era circundado com o coração verde
que significava pra eles e eles disseram
isso este é um amor sustentável ea coisa
mais linda do mundo é que eles tiraram o
sobrenome do homem
eles disseram não ele não merece ter o
mesmo sobrenome que ela então ele vai
ficar sem sobrenome
vejam que coisa maravilhosa e o meu
convite pra vocês
para encerrar a minha fala se júlia e
sofia que são duas das centenas de
meninas com que nós já falamos
acreditam que a diversidade é bom que
respeito é bom que empatia é bom porque
cada um de nós também não pode começar a
mudar o mundo ea aproximar se da
inclusão através da crença de que isso é
possível
muito obrigada